بادئ ذي بدء ، أود أن أهنئكم
على ترشيحكم لجائزة غولدن غلوب ، ما هو
شعورك حيال هذا التقدير
أم أنه من الجيد دائمًا أنه من الجيد أنك تعلم
أننا كنا نتحدث عنه للتو كنتيجة
ثانوية لك تعرف ما نفعله ما
نحبه حقًا هو صنعه
استمع كل عام ، هناك العديد من
العروض المذهلة التي تعرف
أنها لا يتم ملاحظتها بهذه الطريقة ، ومن ثم فإن
الآخرين يبدو الأمر كما لو كان
الأمر رائعًا ، لكن هذا ليس سبب قيامنا بما
نفعله في بابل ، إنه يتعلق بعصر مهم جدًا
هوليوود وقد تم تجاهله نوعًا ما
قبل هذا الفيلم ، كيف تشعر
بأنك جزء من هذا الفيلم
، فأنا مسرور بهذه الطريقة ، ماذا
عنكم يا رفاق ، من فضلك ، هذا جيد ، أنا
سعيد للغاية لأنني أحب ذلك من فضلك فقط لكمة
أنا "  سأستخدم ذلك في مكان ما ولكن آه لا
أعتقد أنه كان من دواعي سروري حقًا أن أحصل
على فرصة للعمل مع داميان لأنني أفترض أن
زملائي في فريق التمثيل كانوا فقط لأننا
كنا معجبين بعمله ، وكذلك
الحصول على فرصة للعمل مع هؤلاء  مع
هؤلاء الناس الذين أنا  من المعجبين بأني من
محبي الأفلام ، لذا حصلت على فرصة
للعمل مع براد ليلي جان دييغو ومارجو ،
كنت هكذا ،
مرحباً ، أنت متحمس ، إنها
حقبة مهمة كما أشرت لأنه إذا كان
هذا هو الوقت الذي كانوا يفكرون فيه.  حتى تعرف كيف
تصنع أفلامًا ، فأنت تعرف ماذا
وكان مفتوحًا على مصراعيها وكان هناك الكثير من
التجارب ، وكان الأمر جنونيًا بعض الشيء
، نعم
يا إلهي [تصفيق] لقد قمت بعمل رائع بالتأكيد في لعب
شخصيتك ، هل يمكنك وصف  ما
هو أصعب مشهد قمت به في هذا
الفيلم ، أعتقد أنه
ليس ما تعتقد أنه
قلق للغاية بشأن كيفية
قيامنا بسحبه ، كما تعلمون كيف
نصارع الأفعى كيف أمتص السم من
رقبة مارجوت ، لقد كان الأمر كذلك.  أعني أنني
أعلم أن الأمر يبدو لذا
فأنت تعلم أنه كان أحد أكبر
اهتماماتي ، كل شيء آخر قمت
بواجبه المنزلي ، قمت ببحثي وكنت
واثقًا من ذلك ، وعندما وصل الأمر إلى هذا
المشهد ، شعرت بالتوتر الشديد ولم أكن أعرف
ماذا  لنفعله ونعم ولكننا قمنا
بإزالته وقمنا
بإزالته  هل تبدو جيدًا ومحترفًا ،
هل كان عليك القيام بأي تدريبات سابقة
لذلك كان علي أن أقوم بكل أنواع
التدريب لأنني لست
لاعب بوق وما زلت غير مخمور
، أعني أنني سئلت من قبل
مثل بعد ذلك  في بعض الأحيان ، يمكنك
أن تلعب دورًا حيث يمكنك تعلم
آلة موسيقية تعلمت الجيتار من قبل
وما زلت أتلاعب بالجيتار ،
لكن البوق عندما تم الانتهاء من ذلك ،
كنت أحب إخراج ذلك من هنا
لأنه أداة صعبة للغاية
لكنك تكتسب الاحترام للأشخاص الذين
أصبحوا جيدين كما هم لأنهم
وضعوا ساعات وساعات وساعات في
كل هذا مثل ربما
إرضاء لاحقًا ولكن ربما ليس بالتأكيد
الكثير من الإخفاقات المبكرة ، لذلك كان من الرائع
أن تلعب دور شخص ما  من هو الموهوب
لكننا تحدثنا في بداية هذه
المقابلة عن مدى جنون هذا الفيلم ،
هل يمكنك أن تصف كيف تم عرضه
على مجموعة مئات الأشخاص الذين يتصرفون في
نفس الوقت ، نعم لقد كانت فوضى منظمة
، أعني هذا ما  ترى في هذه الصورة
هنا هذا كان هذا الذي قمنا بتصويره لمدة أسبوعين
وكان الجميع يقدمون كل ما لديهم
وأنت تعلم من خلال جميع التقارير أن
فكرتنا عن تلك الحقبة كانت معقمة بعض الشيء على
ما يبدو كانت مفتوحة على مصراعيها وكان
الناس يفعلون  مهما كان ما
يتبادر إلى ذهني ، سأترك السؤال
الأخير لكم يا رفاق
، لقد كانت رائعة في هذا الفيلم ، كيف
كان شكل العمل معها ، إنها
قوة الطبيعة كما هي ، لكن هذا
المحترف يتألق عندما نبدأ ، نعم ،
أي شيء تريده  أخبر جميع
معجبيك في الشرق الأوسط في العالم العربي
أه فقط نحن فخورون بهذا
الفيلم حقًا متحمسون جدًا لهذا الفيلم
نعتقد أنه فيلم للشاشة الكبيرة
التي تعرف أن تراها مع أه مع الآخرين
، لذا فهو مضحك  من المضحك
أنسى دائمًا أن الموسيقى كانت رائعة
أيضًا والموسيقى رائعة ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم
يا رفاق ، شكرًا لكم ، أنا أقدر ذلك.